cinquante secondes c'est le temps qu'il
me faut pour faire monter quelqu'un sur
scène parce que je fais du mentalisme à
la base un et la prod m'a dit en plus
tout le monde sera masqué je lis sur les
micro expressions du visage
je crois que le port du masque
obligatoire ça m'ouvre du gouvernement
pour anéantir les mentalistes ok je sais
plus le faire alors je me suis dit une
fois n'est pas coutume je vous fais
rentrer dans mon cerveau le truc pour
moi c'est que quand je vois un mot je le
lis à l'envers c'est comme ça depuis
toujours
donc je je je me suis dit je vais vous
réciter l'alphabet à l'envers soixante
secondes de pur bonheur vraiment z y xwb
l'utc occupés aux nma le cagi agf est
décédé après tu peux faire plus dur tu
peux prendre une lettre de chaque côté à
zenbe y cx dwf j'étais à chelsea hier
j'ai dû capello est humaine voilà ça
c'est bien ça veut dire que par exemple
quand je suis allé voir le film tnet une
seule fois c'est comme si je l'avais vu
quatre fois et ce qu'on pas vu le film
ne comprennent pas la veine et ceux
pourvus qu'une fois ne comprennent pas
le film sur la prochaine fois que vous
allez tout seul vous allez essayer de
dire l'alphabet à l'envers dans votre
tête et vous irez [ __ ] il fait chier
l'autre con dao
[Applaudissements]